do you remember when I asked you for the
solution is to say I think we did the
cube roots of unity rather the cube
roots of unity and just really quickly I
think from memory we got something like
this one solution there to play on 3
negative 2 pi/3 like so okay do you
remember we said oh hi in the pond we
noticed z1 z2 and z3 we're conjugates of
each other can you remember that I also
gave you another one
I think memory again was this ok and
again the solutions were all conjugates
of each other they were all paired up
now when you have a look at these
solutions do I have any conjugates
happening geometrically not your
conjugates look like conjugates are look
at my green line it's a reflection
across the real axis right none of my
answers are reflected off the real ass
axis from each other but they are
related like so ok
excuse me but they're not conjugates ok
so my question is why do I get
conjugates here and here but I didn't
get them here well yeah I have on an
even but you're on the right track what
else is in common between pages that is
not in common with this and you have a
look you can see like the coefficients
of these polynomials right this is a
cubed minus 1 and then this is n to the
6 plus 64 do you notice there are only
real numbers there are no eyes flying
around as soon as you add an eye you get
things that are off axis and they don't
why not perfectly anymore ok now I'm
starting to get into something that's
quite complex and and honestly is
actually really going to be properly
done with when we do polynomials ok but
I can still show you enough of it
because this is actually a really
important point you should see these and
recognize you'll have conjugate
solutions ok
and look at this and say not forget it
I'm just gonna
to do every single board what are we
looking at now I want you to give talk
to shape and there's a side of the sheet
which has a um a title on the side just
gone so be on the side of the title of
the table the title of this is the
complex conjugate roots here boy that's
a mouthful okay I just remember the
theorem just means okay this is true we
can prove it
okay complex roots complex roots we know
what those are and conjugates but we're
noticing that you've got conjugate roots
sometimes but not conjugate roots
other times okay now what I'm gonna do
excuse me is I'm gonna demonstrate like
the missus lesson when you're in trouble
about roots of unity okay so I'm
particularly if you have a look at this
sheet the whole left-hand side they all
roots of unity on the right hand side
then very close to roots of unity but
not what okay so we're gonna start very
simple cases and then we're going to
notice why the complex conjugate roots
theorem says in very very particular
cases the ones I'm gonna look at yard
you will always get complex conjugates
okay so let's begin let's think about a
nice simple case here is their complex
polynomial that's great equals 1 or Z
squared take white 1 equal 0
ok now this is so simple we can just
state the solutions to this right one of
the square roots the complex roots of
one for everything we're about to do
here I'm actually not interested in what
are their actual values were doing when
you're working out don't save it go okay
but I'm just interested in I just want
to make a geometric diamond that's all I
want to do okay
so therefore let's think about this um
the actual square root is m1 one there's
one okay and these are all unit circles
by the way and of course negative one
yes so both of those disparities so I'm
gonna put in beyond I'm gonna put the
modulus need as well I'm gonna mark that
it's go from the origin there is my
solution because it one and there's my
solution present to their rights to
ounces
okay now what we're thinking about this
right I won't even think about what's
the relationship between Zed squared
equals one and Zed Square D was negative
one now in the real field right but feel
a couple it's not real numbers this is
miss submissions right but we have no
idea in the field of real numbers for
any complex plane right so that's why I
have all these solutions up here what
are the two solutions but since when he
was making one good like that's the one
by definition or call that was it one if
I thought we can say because it's so
easy I'll identify it as I and then what
you've got is Z 2 which is negative PI
and if you square that the negatives
cancel you just get every I squared
which by definition is negative 1 happy
times
ok what's happening here is it cubed we
did this one and we have our solution is
right the first solution when K equals 0
is still gonna be one isn't it ok it's
gonna be one in fact spoiler this right
I've got 10 squared is that cubes into
the full all the way up to Z to the 7
right you're always going to get or the
left-hand column what is always a
solution
of course it is right 1 squared is 1 and
1 cubed is 1 1 is always one of citizens
ok sometimes I'm gonna put put the
solution back because I know I'm gonna
get intervention okay all right now what
are the other two solutions remember
they are evenly spaced out on the
circumference ok now the angle the
center is 360 degrees or two pi radians
so therefore the angle between each of
the three lines for my three solutions
is 360 divided by 3 or 2 pi divided by
320 breeze the reason I say that is
because you can roughly kind of do 103
degrees right so hybrid everybody's from
Zed 1 which is 1
this is gonna be where that shoe is and
there's two pilots three okay
now is what I want to point out to you
this is really significant we're going
throughout a equals zero one I always
tell you
all right at a certain point you stop
going forward start going forward it's
gonna take you out of the principal
argument right and we start looking at
the negatives now being that what is a
solution that's tank receiver and here's
this answer in here cake was one now
what I do K equals negative one right
it's going to take the same gap to pile
on three but it's gonna go instead of
anti-clockwise it's gonna be a clockwise
to see that by the same amount
this way from the positive real axis now
that because the argument is exactly the
same as in two but negative that gives
me is that three over here but because
look I rotated the same amount this way
anti-clockwise and the same that this
way clockwise so necessarily these two
have to be vertically above or below
each other does that make sense like
you're going the same angle this way say
they will that way so that's what makes
these guys conjugates see that okay yeah
this is a bit trickier we didn't do this
example
but I wonder if you can work it out with
you Zed cute equals negative one though
okay now I'll give you an easy one right
again there's a single real solution but
it's not 1 because 1 cubed is not
negative 1 what's the real solution is
gonna be negative 1 right because they
didn't one times negative 1 times 1/2 of
the negatives will cancel that would
they do be negative 1 over here okay
yeah it is that will get there once we
give the answers okay that is
interesting right say cubed equals
negative one kill me quickly they're
easy numbers can we quickly actually
work out the solutions to this because
we know what the solutions are here okay
so Zed cubed equals negative 1 by
tomorrow's here if I can stay
that's our cute cos 3 theta plus I sine
theta right what's it equal to what is
it negative 1 even more doubtful it has
a bunch of soft one because that's its
distance from the origin right and what
is the argument that takes me from the
positive real axis
all the way around to remind hi very
good so I've got cos Phi plus I sine PI
now from this I mean okay the modulus is
fine I mean we're on the unit circle so
let me deal but when I look at the angle
right three theta equals three yes okay
two K PI for integer values of K and now
we'll divide by three which gives me PI
on three plus okay
now hold on a second he's the first
solution that I know about I'm not gonna
call it is n1 because what's the K value
don't get me to this solution this is
high right now so PI over 3 plus 2 times
1 point 3 that's PI 3 plus 2 pi 3 that's
fine
so this is actually K equals 1 that's
actually the second solution I'm gonna
get right what's the best solution
pumpkin it's pilot rate which is
somewhere
not so much in a way like they're all
there already doesn't matter that
whatever but I do want to like I'm
trying to make an argument that actually
does depend on the order that we get to
the solutions in anime so specifically I
went up here
Payan three right you see what that and
then I went another suit by I'm three to
get all the way to PI does that make
sense so there's my said one sorry
and there's my said to okay now
obviously I've had the principal argue
already so how do I get the next the
last solution - you did negative one
right now negative one is going to be
negative 2 pi on three from zip one
right so it's going to be down here see
that I've gone negative 2 PI over 3
so therefore what's the actual argument
of this Zen 3 - its pilot 3 - 2 pi 3
which is negative PI on 3 that's this
argument here again just like I had in
Zen cubed equals positive 1 I've got 2
pi and 3 anti-clockwise and then I got -
to pilot 3 which is clockwise and I've
got the same scenario here it's just a
different size angle so again I have
these complex conjugates you see and
negative 1 is its own conjugate because
negative 1 plus or minus 0 I it's plus 0
is a - you are right okay now what
patents is time to emerge you thinking
it's still a bit early so you might not
get you ok zin to the 4 equals 1 we
already know what the first version is
is it was good one
these are evenly spaced how many other
before just like you know right just
like you but the difference is right
instead of starting a pile of 12 and
then going around right angle running
running I'm starting at 1 or an argument
0
zero is a better way to set because I
was talking about angles here right so
therefore I go around PI onto which has
me here which of course is censored
equals to I because the plus it is
because I the power 4 is negative 1 the
power 2 which is 1 and then you've got
your other solutions all spaced out
evenly around the circumference and then
I would take a K equals negative 1 to
get to this one yeah so this is fine I
will leave it to you to try and work out
why I have left the spaceman he went and
we're going to turn over the page